aujourd'hui contrairement à d'habitude
il n'y aura pas de nouvelles épisodes
sur cette chaîne la raison en est simple
l'épisode prévu aujourd'hui porté sur
shopenhauer et les femmes et en raison
des propos qui sont tenus par l'auteur
la vidéo fait l'objet d'une restriction
par YouTube sur Youtube les règles
d'utilisation se sont durci depuis
plusieurs années interdisant désormais
vous le voyez à l'écran les sujets
controversés les propos choquants les
contenus jugés haineux provoquant ou
dénigrants bien entendu la définition de
ces termes est largement subjective car
qui juge de ce qu'est un propos choquant
ajoutons un slack que l'algorithme
YouTube ne fait pas la différence entre
un propos haineux et un propos qui
commente analyse voire dénonce ce propos
haineux son but est de plaire aux
annonceurs publicitaires en éliminant
tout risque de polémique pour toutes ces
raisons et comme je vous l'avais annoncé
dans ma dernière FAQ mon épisode sur
shopenhauer et les femmes sera
disponible uniquement sur ma page
patronne une plateforme payante sur
laquelle je publie mon contenu inédit et
qui n'est pour l'instant pas soumise à
la censure si vous souhaitez voir cet
épisode vous savez ce qu'il vous reste à
faire le lien est dans la description je
précise d'ailleurs que même si
shopenhauer est effectivement un auteur
misogyne et virulent dans ses propos
l'épisode en question ne comporte pas de
propos particulièrement haineux ou
choquant ce sont simplement des propos
d'un autre siècle qu'il serait
anachronique de juger à la lumière de
notre modernité inclusive merci pour
votre compréhension et pour les plus
motivés rendez-vous sur patronne